carbon capture isn't real wait yes it is
here in Switzerland a giant new machine
is sucking carbon directly from the air
developers say the plant will capture
about 900 tons of CO2 annually or the
approximate level released from 200 cars
or how about the world's largest carbon
capture plant Orca in Iceland designed
to filter up to 4 000 tons of CO2 a year
yes these projects do exist and they do
suck CO2 out of the atmosphere but
carbon capture is advertised still isn't
real let me explain so the Orca each
year captures 4 000 tons of CO2
translating to about 11 tons per day or
about half a ton per hour capturing one
ton of CO2 costs 2 650 kilowatt hours or
so they say so here's the problem the
average Coal Power Plant spews out about
a kilogram of CO2 per kilowatt hour
meaning to produce those 2650 kilowatt
hours necessary to capture one ton of
CO2 the average coal power plant has to
emit 2.65 tons of CO2 so if you run this
carbon capture plant of a Coal Power
Plant you'll capture one ton and produce
2.65 tons
if your fossil power plant is the
cleanest type IE natural gas and is
brand new and efficient you'll produce
about 1.06 tons practically breaking
even hang on a second we have this thing
called Green energy if we run our carbon
capture plant of that we no longer emit
CO2 problem solved right and no if your
energy mix contains any amount of fossil
fuels your carbon capture plant will be
consuming green energy that could have
been used to replace fossil fuel
production so if the carbon capture
plant eats one megawatt of green energy
now a fossil fuel plant has to increase
production by one megabyte to cover the
hole and you obviously can't increase
green energy production at the turn of a
dial you can't control the wind speed or
the sun's brightness okay but what about
nuclear it's zero emission and we can
increase production at the turn of a
dial sure but we should already be doing
that if you could turn up a nuclear
power plant to cover the needs of carbon
capture plants well then why are we
bothering with the carbon capture plant
to begin with let's just turn up the
nuclear plant by default to replace
fossil fuel production thereby reducing
CO2 emissions okay then what about a
power grid that isn't connected to any
other power grids and that operates on
100 renewable energy like like Iceland
where the Orca plant is not
coincidentally if we plug a carbon
capture plant into that grid that's
absolutely a net decrease in CO2 right
no if Iceland doesn't have enough green
Surplus to operate Orca you'll have to
build a solar farm let's say to supply
it but then why not build the solar farm
in other countries to reduce their
fossil fuel consumption thus their CO2
emission and if Iceland does have enough
green Surplus to operate Orca why not
just move stuff like server Parks or
data centers to Iceland from other
countries to run them off the green
Surplus thereby reducing fossil fuel
consumption and my God we haven't even
talked about things like emissions from
Transportation at full capacity the Orca
plant eliminates the annual emissions of
870 cars do you know what else can
eliminate the annual emissions of 870
cars a couple of new bus lanes and bike
paths and you don't even need megawatts
of electricity to operate those so if
you're a company interested in reducing
CO2 why not just help fund bus lanes and
bike pads instead that's because these
carbon capture plants are part of the
same Tech progress that has been going
on for years now I.E you don't have to
change your lifestyle you can take your
three gigs to three separate trainings
with your gigantic SUV five times per
week instead of taking public transit
you can keep eating beef and similar
animal products every day instead of
switching to more environmentally
friendly Foods Because by the power of
the science God there's this plant
somewhere that sucks the CO2 you produce
out of the air through the magic of
science this will be the equivalent of
you taking a crap in the middle of your
living room instead of walking all the
way to the toilet so some company
announces a brand new AI enhanced [ __ ]
cleaner Roomba to keep your living room
tidy no just stop [ __ ] on the floor
go to the toilet and if you don't have
one build one and this is why carbon
capture isn't real and by this I mean
the concept of carbon capture being a
good alternative to other measures the
technology itself is of course real it's
just pointless as things stand now
thank you for watching if you like my
content don't forget to subscribe and
also there is a membership option on my
channel and you can also support me on
patreon if you want to support me making
content like this see you next time